comment conduire par temps froid le
pilote automobile stéphane panepinto est
venu tester ce jour-ci sur le circuit
beltoise à trappes une voiture équipée
de roulettes le but simuler les plaques
de verglas avant de se lancer sur la
route le pilote recommande de s'assurer
du bon fonctionnement du véhicule des
freins des essuie glaces et de s'équiper
de pneus hiver
déjà c'est reconnaissables par le
symbole qui est dessiné sur le pneu on
voit les flocons de neige
donc ça c'est la première chose ensuite
on voit là le dessin du pneu les
sculptures qui sont beaucoup plus
profondes ce qui permet une meilleure
évacuation soit de l'oci neige pas où
l'accumulation de la neige parce qu'il
faut savoir que rien n'avait mieux sur
la neige que la neige donc le fait que
la neige s'accumule dans les sculptures
permet une meilleure adhérence ensuite
dans la voiture le spécialiste insiste
sur le fait d'être bien installé d'avoir
la tête bien droite ne pas être trop
couvert il faut avoir un pare brise bien
propre et sans lui et objectif pouvoir
anticiper au maximum sur la route pack
de verglas alors déjà il faut qu'on ait
une vitesse adaptée ça c'est essentiel
sinon pourra jamais maîtriser le
véhicule
ensuite ces deux légèrement poser le
pied sur le frein sans trop freiner pour
ne pas bloquer les roues parce que c'est
là où arrivent les difficultés c'est on
bloque les roues on perd le contrôle de
la voiture irrattrapable parce qu'en
plus la voiture va prendre de la vitesse
donc on accentue le danger en cas de
fortes neiges sur les routes yvelinoise
le pilote stéphane pénet pinto vous
recommande de rester chez vous et de
télétravailler